the way I'm really using AI personally
right now is to help me think through
observations I'll give you a for
instance I may type in a query that's
like hey I'm noticing that a lot of men
are growing out their hair longer is
there any data that supports that men
are cutting their hair less often in the
last six months in America like I could
see me asking that opening question
leading me to starting a toothpaste
brand because we got into male grooming
and somehow I ended up realizing like oh
there aren't enough clean toothpastes
for men that are positioned that way
because it's all made for like
contemporary Coastal females right now
and I need to make a bro toothpaste now
what I do for a living is really human
psychology consumer behavior and so for
me AI is going to be incredible thought
partner with me